[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportage sur Public Sénat vous le savez
on est ensemble tous les jours du lundi
au jeudi à 18h et 22h pour donner du
sens à l'actualité grâce à nos experts
demain Elisabeth borne fête ses 1 an à
Matignon elle restera celle qui a fait
passer en force une réforme des
retraites sans majorité à l'Assemblée
forcément son image en partie quel bilan
quel équilibre dans sa relation avec
Emmanuel Macron que retiennent les
Français de l'action de leur première
ministre on en débat dans une minute et
puis en Turquie il faudra bien un second
tour pour désigner le président mais
contrairement à ce que annonçait les
sondages c'est le sortant erdonan qui
bascule en tête avec plus de 49% des
suffrages son challenger Kemal killics
je suis là vous êtes là vous aussi et je
jure par Dieu que nous nous battrons
jusqu'au bout je suis là
Erdogan peut-il encore perdre sa dérive
autoritaire va-t-elle continuer quelles
conséquences sa réélection aurait sur
les relations avec la France et l'Europe
réponse dans trois quarts d'heure mais
d'abord les temps forts de la première
année d'Elizabeth borne à la tête du
gouvernement avec Quentin Calmet
16 mai 2022 Elisabeth borne succède à
Jean Castex à Matignon le début de 12
mois riche en rebondissements en
déplacement à la Réunion la première
ministre évoque une année intense
presque un euphémisme on un an 27 textes
ont été adoptés c'est un bilan solide
nous avons conduit des réformes
difficiles mais indispensables flashback
en juillet dernier Élisabeth borne entre
véritablement dans la lumière face à une
Assemblée nationale très turbulente lors
de son discours de politique générale la
deuxième première ministre dans
l'histoire évoque son père et ce qu'elle
doit à la République si je suis ici
devant vous
première ministre de la France je le
dois à la République c'est elle qui m'a
tendu la main en me faisant pupille de
la nation alors que j'étais cet enfant
dont le père n'était jamais vraiment
revenu des camps
[Musique]
dès son premier été à la tête du
gouvernement la première ministre
enchaîne les crises entre une inflation
galopante une grève des salariés dans
les raffineries ou encore des risques de
pénurie d'électricité mais si chacun ne
prend pas sa part nous serions amenés à
imposer des baisses de consommation à
l'automne elle traverse de fortes
turbulences aussi dans le champ
politique privé de majorité absolue à
l'Assemblée nationale à première
ministre doit multiplier le recours aux
49.3 pour faire adopter les textes
budgétaires
dégage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement pour la première partie du
projet de loi de finance pour 2023 à
peine le cap des six mois passés une
nouvelle crise se profile dès la
présentation de la réforme des retraites
les syndicats alertes ils ne veulent pas
d'un décalage de l'âge de départ sans
suivront des mois de bras de fer avec la
rue et un marathon parlementaire
tumultueux le 16 mars Elisabeth borne
déclenche un nouveau 49-3
75 heures de débat parlementaire
s'effondrer aussi sur le fondement de
l'article de 49 alinéa 3 de la
Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement quelques jours plus tard
Elisabeth borne échappe à la censure à
neuf voix près pour sortir de la crise
politique et sociale Emmanuel Macron
donne 100 jours à sa première ministre
le 26 avril elle présente une feuille de
route dont l'échéance arrivera à terme
le 14 juillet un compte à rebours dont
le tic-tac doit hanter aujourd'hui les
murs de l'hôtel de Matignon
ce compte à rebours tient ce sera l'un
des thèmes évidemment de notre débat
j’accueil Franck Morel bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes avocat associé chez Flichy
Grangé et ancien conseiller social
d'Edouard Philippe expert emploie
également à l'Institut Montaigne busina
bonsoir anne-charlaine bienvenue à vous
vous êtes constitutionnaliste
j'accueille également Pierre-Adrien
Bartoli bonsoir et bienvenue directeur
des études politiques chez Harris
Interactive Mathieu croissanto bonsoir
Mathieu tout va bien alors on peut
démarrer vous êtes toujours
éditorialiste politique et c'est
toujours un plaisir de vous accueillir
sur ce plateau partagez allez on va
faire un petit tour de table pour
démarrer un grand d'ailleurs il y a rien
de petit dans cette émission un adjectif
pour qualifier résumé peut-être cette
première année de d'Elizabeth borne à
Matignon Franck Morel je commence avec
vous vous dites quoi elle a été le bilan
est plutôt honorable mais l'année a été
mouvementée voilà
et bilan honorable ouais bilan honorable
Einstein bizina pour résumer tient son
peut-être la personnalité le caractère
d'isabeth band vous diriez quoi
quand même dans cette année qui se
dégage c'est à dire que on a quand même
eu sous la Cinquième République des
premiers ministres qui ont eu des
périodes un petit peu plus calmes et
donc là autant dire qu'elle est arrivée
dans une dans un avis en pleine tempête
et que donc il y a quelque chose de
l'ordre de la de la témérité en tout cas
du de la ténacité elle a elle a démontré
que non seulement elle voulait tenir
mais je crois qu'elle entretient assez
bien cette image finalement pour
laquelle d'ailleurs elle avait peut-être
été préalablement choisie de
dureté parfois dans la négociation mais
pour parvenir à sortir aussi d'ailleurs
son épingle du jeu peut-être en tout cas
en démontrant que elle n'a pas peur de
prendre les décisions et de les endosser
Pierre-Adrien Bartoli votre votre mot
votre objectif et puis peut-être aussi
ce que les Français retiennent de de
cette première année de de pouvoir des
événements je serai sur le même mot
c'est courageuse courageuse c'est le
premier caletic explicatif que les
Français attribuent à la première
ministre on a bien vu que en termes
d'opinion en termes de popularité tout
était pas au beau fixe même si on pourra
y revenir c'est plus nuancé que mais
quand même on lui reconnaît et
d'ailleurs de plus en plus avec la fin
de cette séquence des retraites une
forme de courage à faire face à une
situation politique dont elle est pas
jugée comme étant responsable on
considère pas que c'est elle qui a perdu
en tant que chef de la majorité les
élections législatives et qu'elle a une
majorité relative à l'Assemblée donc
elle fait face aux événements avec
courage donc ça sera le terme est-ce
qu'elle est à des niveaux de popularité
Mathieu préparé vous est-ce qu'elle est
à des niveaux de produits
similaires
après un an de ces prédécesseurs alors
la tendance est similaire le niveau
n'est pas vraiment c'est que nous on l'a
on la mesure à 35% de confiance dans
notre baromètre elle est neuf points
plus bas par rapport à ce que là où elle
était il y a un an pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle est plus bas depuis d'ailleurs
Jean-Marc Ayraud c'est lui qui était à
30% donc été en dessous parmi les
derniers Premier ministre pourquoi
est-ce qu'elle est plus bas parce qu'en
fait elle partait dès le départ de plus
bas avec une notoriété qui était quand
même assez faible et puis première
ministre dans un deuxième quinquennat
c'est évidemment pas un rôle très facile
on voit très bien comment les choses se
sont construites donc le retrait ou le
recul de ces bonnes opinions sont
similaires à ce qu'on vécu ces
prédécesseurs toujours autour de 7 8 10
points Jean-Marc Hérault pour rappel
c'est 60 %
de confiance moi 1 30 % un an plus tard
à moins 30 points là on n'est pas du
tout sur le même niveau on est à moins 9
points c'est assez standard mais
effectivement comme elle partait de plus
bas elle est plutôt dans le bas du
classement Mathieu moi je dirais
résiliente
résiliente parce que c'est vrai qu'elle
est courageuse c'est vrai qu'il y a une
forme de témérité et surtout une
capacité absorber les coûts et encaisser
les chocs qui est assez remarquable pour
le coup c'est une première ministre qui
a été choisie mais mal choisi puisque ce
n'était pas le premier choix du
président c'est une première ministre à
la tête d'une majorité qui a été une
mauvaise majorité puisqu'elle n'a pas la
majorité absolue donc ça fait quand même
descendre dès le début de de son séjour
à Matignon des des haies assez compliqué
à franchir et puis ensuite petit à et
elle a essayé d'imprimer sa marque et
puis elle est quand même très cornaqué
par l'Élysée donc c'est pas toujours
facile avec des formes d'injonction qui
peuvent paraître parfois contradictoires
et puis laisser quand même pris dans la
figure un conflit social comme on en
avait pas vu en France depuis près de 25
ans de 30 ans donc voilà restez tenir
son cap quoi qu'on pense de sa politique
quoi qu'on pense de ce qu'elle met en
place je trouve qu'il y a une chez elle
une forme de résilience d'une capacité à
tenir bon et encaisser les chocs et à
tracer sa voix Franck Morel pendant
qu'on regardait le sujet de Quentin
Calmet il y a évidemment cette image qui
est sans doute restera à l'image la plus
forte de son de cette première année
c'est ce moment où elle où elle annonce
le 49-3 enfin et est-ce que je fais
souvent quand vous êtes sur ce plateau
et Féro ça va vous souvenir de Matignon
et ça ne vous empêche pas d'avoir des
analyses évidemment qui sortent de ça
mais est-ce que vous avez souvenir
d'un climat pareil moi je le mot qui me
vin c'est soufflant d'une soufflante
pareil voilà subie par Édouard Philippe
quand il était pour monter très loin
effectivement alors je remonterai pas
comme comme Mathieu croissanto à 25 30
ans je remettrai à moins de 15 ans en
2010 il y a eu une réforme des retraites
donc il y a 13 ans et le climat avait
été déjà extrêmement éruptif en revanche
mais avec une assemblée qui est alors
avec notre équilibre qui disposait d'une
majorité absolue avec des débats
parlementaires extrêmement violents
aussi le président de l'Assemblée avait
été poursuivi jusque dans ses
appartements donc il y a eu des moments
extrêmement durs aussi à ce moment-là
mais j'ai pas souvenir effectivement
pendant la période de début du précédent
quinquennat et en tout cas pendant la
première année parce qu'après il y a eu
la la question la période gilet jaune
qui était aussi marqué par un climat
extrêmement compliqué différent de
celui-ci parce que marquer aussi par un
refus des représentations refus des
corps intermédiaires contestation très
très forte de qui prétend représenter ce
qui était pas le cas ici mais j'ai pas
souvenir effectivement dans la première
année du début du quinquennat en 2017
d'avoir vécu un tel climat ça a été un
climat extrêmement compliqué et on peut
dire que cette première année est une
année d'une certaine manière mono
quasiment mono-sujet monothématiques
puisque la séquence réforme des
retraites a éclipser tout ce qui a pu se
passer auparavant la première ministre
dans sa communication met en avant le
fait qu'il y a eu 27 textes dans
l'Italie au Journal du Dimanche
si on faisait un petit sondage comme ça
informel on à peine à se souvenir de
quel texte il s'agit tant la séquence
retraite à tout je dirais à tout éclipsé
et donc effectivement je pense qu'avec
le recul du temps quand on quand on aura
laissé passer un petit peu de de moi et
d'année sur cette période et bien c'est
sans doute moi c'est le pari que je fais
c'est sans doute cette dimension courage
capacité à réformer qui sera sans doute
retenue par rapport à cette période et
d'ailleurs peut-être que ça infusera sur
une longue durée dans l'opinion et ça ça
nourrira une future carrière politique
on verra bien on voit on n'est pas là
pour tirer des plans sur la comète mais
on va s'appuyer sur alors on a cherché à
tout dernier baromètre fait par l'un de
vos confrères en l'occurrence et donc ça
pour Le Figaro sur les qualificatifs qui
s'appliquent plus ou moins bien à
Elisabeth borne alors les qualificatifs
positifs pour commencer c'est le mot
solide ça rejoint un peu ce qu'on a dit
ici qui ressort le premier avec 57% de
de oui ayant de l'autorité 57%, le
dynamisme alors là on part sous la on
passe sous la barre des 50 mais quand
même 46% de oui et la compétence 44%
pire Adrien Bertoli est-ce que avec ces
traits de voilà de de caractère ou c'est
qualificatif vous avez commencé
l'évoquer mais la première Miss réussit
comment ça se démarquer du présent de la
République c'est un peu ce qu'on voit
dans nos enquêtes et ce qui est assez
étonnant c'est que c'est quelque chose
qui aurait dû être fait dès le départ
parce que c'est des presque là le
casting initial au départ on cherchait
une première ministre qui soit en mesure
d'être plus horizontale dans la
concertation avec les collectivités
territoriales que la connu en tant que
préfet de région avec les corps
intermédiaires les syndicats qu'elle a
connu en tant que dirigeante de la RATP
pour contrebalancer quelque part ce côté
très vertical du président de la
République dont on sait que lui pour le
coup aurait été très en surplomb et ça a
pas marché et dès le départ en termes
d'opinion par exemple on a eu une
indexation de sa cote de confiance à
elle sur celle du président quand ça a
progressé pour le président ça a
progressé pour elle quand ça baisser
pour le président ça a baissé pour elle
également donc elle était vraiment le
décalque dans l'opinion du Président de
la République là on l'a vu il y a à peu
près 2-3 semaines on a une désindexation
c'est à dire qu'on a une évolution de
cette confiance qui ne converge plus
mais à l'inverse divers je dirais un
président de la République qui reste un
peu englué dans des niveaux de confiance
assez bas suite à la réforme des
retraites et à l'inverse une première
ministre qui rebondit elle prend quatre
points chez nous à partir du moment où
elle montre qu'elle peut avoir un espace
politique qui lui est propre sans aller
jusqu'à dire qu'elle a une ligne qui lui
est propre en tout cas elle peut exister
par elle-même au-delà de l'ombre du
président que lui laisser le président
de la République et ça c'est assez
nouveau parce qu'elle s'appuie en
faisant ça sur premièrement ce qui est
son image maximum de résiliente fidèles
et quand même ayant c'est sa propre
dimension son propre cursus et portant
c'est ses propres valeurs et puis
deuxièmement traçant sa propre ligne
programmatique où on se rend bien compte
et entre le Président de la République
et elle la direction et la même mais le
chemin pour atteindre ces directions-là
n'est pas toujours exactement autour du
projet de loi immigration par exemple du
timing du tempo on va dire pour pour
faire passer éventuellement cette loi on
annonçait un challenge première ministre
technicienne est-ce qu'elle se révèle
plus politique que prévu après vous moi
je crois qu'en tout cas elle joue
quelque chose d'important dans la
personnalisation de son action aussi et
on le voit surtout après le débat
parlementaire en fait de la réforme des
retraites où elle a essayé de peut-être
jouer aussi la corde empathique qui est
un petit peu manqué au président de la
République à la suite des premières
semaines de de combat un peu de rue etc
et donc je crois qu'en fait elle elle a
une bonne conscience en tout cas de ce
qui est le rôle qu'elle peut jouer dans
ces moments-là et le rôle du Premier
ministre il est vraiment pas facile sous
la Cinquième République déjà je cite un
article de doctrine qui était assez
rigolo au bout d'un an de 5e République
où on avait un article qui s'intitulait
Michel Debré existe-t-il donc on voit
bien que déjà la question c'était posée
et je crois que justement tout cet enjeu
d'avoir une identité tout en étant quand
même suffisamment aux ordres puisque on
le sait sous la Cinquième République
tour remonte et tout revient au
président de la République est un enjeu
sur lequel elle a eu l'air de trouver en
tout cas un équilibre récent précaire et
peut-être celui-ci ne lui permet-il
celui-ci ne lui permettra-t-il pas
d'aller au bout de au bout d'un mandat
ou en tout cas on verra bien mais je
crois qu'en tout cas là elle a trouvé
une ligne personnelle et ça je pense que
ça a fait la différence il y a quand
même un aspect paradoxal qui convient de
souligner c'est que le choix stratégique
autour de la manière d'appréhender la
réforme des retraites qui a été celui de
faire un accord avec les de tenter de
faire un accord avec les républicains et
de partir non pas sur du 65 mais sur du
64 au nom de cet accord avec les
républicains
il semble que ça soit un choix
stratégique qui est plutôt été proposé
par Matignon et qui a donné ce que l'on
sait en terme de parcours compliqué
chaotique effectivement de la réforme et
semble-t-il comme vous l'avez souligné
tout à l'heure c'est pas quelque chose
qui est mis à son débit
alors même que d'un point de vue
purement factuel on pourrait se dire le
président de la République était plutôt
sur une ligne semble-t-il au début du
processus consistant à y aller carrément
par un amendement au PLFSS au projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale et plutôt sur 65
le film qui se serait déroulé aurait été
tout autre est-ce que les choses
auraient été plus simples peut-être au
Parlement en tout cas elles auraient été
plus simple dans l'opinion publique
c'est une autre affaire mais en tout cas
ce qui est certain c'est que la pense
telle qu'elle a été organisée a conduit
aux grandes difficultés que l'on connaît
dans l'adoption de la réforme et c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas perçu dans
l'opinion publique et ce qui renvoie
sans doute à ce que vous disiez sur des
fondamentaux en réalité très basique
très permanent sur la répartition des
rôles entre le Président de la
République et le Premier ministre et
j'ai envie de dire vous parliez de
Michel Debré j'ai envie de dire encore
plus depuis le quinquennat c'est à dire
que la tendance c'est encore accentuée
depuis le quinquennat et depuis la
coïncidence l'inversion voilà entre les
mandats présidentielles et les mandats
du Parlement alors on va évidemment de
temps entendre dans ce débat réécouter
des des passages un peu marquants de
cette première année d'Elizabeth borne à
Matignon puisqu'on parle de la réforme
des retraites je vous propose d'écouter
un extrait de son discours de politique
générale on est donc au mois de juillet
premier exercice de pédagogie sur les
retraites premier exercice d'une longue
série
pour la prospérité de notre pays et la
pérennité de notre système par
répartition pour bâtir de nouveaux
progrès sociaux pour qu'aucun retraiter
avec une carrière complète n'est qu'une
pension inférieure à 1100 euros par mois
pour sortir de situations où le même
métier ne garantit pas la même retraite
oui nous devrons travailler
progressivement un peu plus longtemps
Matthieu sur le sur le sens politique
des abonnements c'est une question
compliquée elle est arrivée on lui a
fait tout de suite un procès d'intention
en disant une techno elle ne connaît
rien la politique et puis le premier pas
ont quand même été marqué par discours
de politique générale qui était plutôt
astucieux et bien senti et très vite
c'est imposé l'image plutôt d'une
honnête femme qui allait mener la barque
gouvernementale comme elle le pouvait au
mieux puis ensuite l'honnête femme s'est
fait blouser si j'ose le dire vous
l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure parce que
son choix à la fois tactique et
stratégique de de
d'entamer la réforme des retraites en
dévoilant toutes ces cartes et en misant
sur le du cheval entre guillemets
puisqu'elle a misé sur les républicains
on peut pas dire que c'est une maestria
politique ou c'est un sens politique
particulier surtout que alors évidemment
c'est toujours très facile de réécrire
l'histoire après mais voilà on savait
que la désignation d'Éric ciottier à
tête des républicains c'était pas fait
sans mal que l'on savait qu'il y avait
des parmi eux voilà quelques dissensions
donc c'était pas forcément certain et
puis elle a sous-estimé aussi les
syndicats il faut le dire et ça on
imaginant pas que notamment la CFDT
irait dans la rue comme elle a été et ça
c'est pas forcément avoir du flair
politique par ailleurs elle a fait
quelques autres fautes de car sur le
49-3 ce qu'il fallait le dégainer ou
prendre son risque ça ça reste un débat
mais quand elle a dit quelques quelques
jours après qu'elle ne ferait plus
jamais de 49-3 sauf pour les textes
budgétaires personne ne la forçait ça a
invalidé tout ce qu'elle avait dit
auparavant bref voilà et en même temps
elle subit un démenti du président de la
République dans les 24 heures et en même
temps vis-à-vis du président de la
République elle arrive quand même à
marquer un petit peu de sa patte vous
souvenez de son appréciation de la
situation au lendemain de l'adoption de
la réforme des retraites qui nécessitait
que la France la France était en
convalescence selon elle est nécessité
une période d'apaisement un mot qui a
été repris par la suite par le Président
de la République voilà elle arrive à
imposer par petites touches
une méthode borne mais la méthode borne
reste coincée parce que il l'offre
politique enfin la situation politique
fait qu'elle a quoi c'est sa tire moins
à elle que évidemment la situation je
vous donne la parole tout de suite
Franck mais pierrelayer sur ce point
précis de la réforme des retraites
est-ce que les Français sont de plus en
plus nombreux à vouloir tourner cette
page alors
disons que les choses sont un peu figées
vis-à-vis de la réforme des retraites
parce qu'aujourd'hui les gens
s'expriment moins sur le fond du texte
que ce qu'il y a derrière et ce qui est
derrière c'est à nouveau toujours cette
structuration de l'espace politique en
trois pôles mais qui aujourd'hui sont
extrêmement nettes dans nos enquêtes et
des deux tiers qui représentent en gros
la gauche réunis autour de la France
insoumise et la droite de la droite à ce
moment national grosso modo reste très
opposé à toute politique du gouvernement
donc ça ça clôt l'affaire et donc ils
vont rester
en opposition à cette réforme quelle
qu'on soit la séquence non ce qui est
plutôt intéressant c'est de voir que le
gouvernement est en train de réussir lui
à la tourner et c'est toute la séquence
médiatique qu'on vit aujourd'hui il y a
cette effectivement séquence un an
d'Elizabeth borne à Matignon qui permet
de revenir en arrière et de
voir l'histoire et voir le parcours qui
a été
emprunté par la première ministre sous
un jour qui est quand même différente
celui qu'on aurait commenté il y a
quelques semaines et quelques semaines
faut pas oublier que Elizabeth borne
c'est la première ministre qui ne
connaît pas les Français qui en est
complètement coupé exactement comme le
président de la République d'ailleurs
c'est le principal critique qui continue
d'exister et là on n'a pas encore parlé
autour de la table parce qu'on sent bien
qu'il y a une autre histoire qui est en
train de s'écrire
quelle nourrit d'ailleurs elle-même qui
est celle d'une personne on dira jamais
sous le genou mais qui en tout cas peut
pas être complètement libre parce que le
rôle ne le permet pas donc doit essayer
de trouver un chemin compliqué pour
exister à côté d'un président de la
République qui lui cristallise les
différentes
crispations et puis même de toute façon
les les différentes attaques des
Français qui sont en désaccord avec la
politique mais également ce qu'il ce
qu'il porte et on l'a vu se basculement
se faire notamment dans les
manifestations à l'occasion de la
réforme des retraites autour de la
manière dont est passé le texte en gros
la question du 49-3 c'est la bascule
également du gouvernement vers le
président de la République c'est le
moment où on se rend compte qu'on est
plus sur une opposition au fond du texte
mais à la manière dont on gouverne la
France et la personne qui gouverne la
France paradoxalement c'est le président
de la République et pas le gouvernement
et donc les pancartes dans les
manifestations à ce moment-là était pas
enfin marqué bande d'émission c'était
Macron démission et attaquer le
locataire d'Elysée et pas Matignon
franchement elle voulait intervenir je
vais vous laisser dire ce que vous
vouliez mais le 49-3 est-ce que cette ce
temps politique
d'évaluer le 49-3 pour longtemps d'après
vous alors pour longtemps je n'en sais
rien mais en tout cas ce qui est dommage
c'est effectivement d'avoir
inutilement de mon point de vue
dramatiser le non recours aux 49-3
pendant des semaines et des semaines
pour finalement y avoir recours et
j'allais mieux le banaliser voilà le
gouvernement c'est un peu tirer une
balle dans le pied de ce point de vue là
parce que il aurait dû au contraire
banaliser à outrance la question du
recours au 49-3 c'est une vraie question
en tout cas sur le devenir du 49-3 parce
que moi je à titre personnel je regrette
que le chant du 49.3 a été restreint en
2008 parce que c'est un outil qui est un
outil qui reste démocratique puisque il
faut qu'il y ait une majorité pour
censurer et pour proposer de fait une
alternative un gouvernement et donc ça
renvoie aussi à la question du
quinquennat ça renvoie à toute une série
de questions sur la nécessité peut-être
de revenir un certain nombre de
fondamentaux de la Cinquième République
des origines de la Cinquième République
moi je voudrais revenir par rapport à
Elisabeth borne sur quelque chose qui
est intéressant en termes d'éclairage du
parcours des Elisabeth borne c'est les
dossiers qu'elle a eu à traiter dans ces
précédents portefeuilles ministériels en
tant que ministre du Travail et encore
avant en tant que ministre des
Transports elle a eu quand même deux
réformes qui étaient quand même des
réformes pas faciles qui étaient d'un
côté quand elle était ministre des
Transports la réforme de la SNCF qui
s'est soldé quand même pas mal de
manifestations des conflits sociaux
assez costaud et pour lequel elle a
réussi à trouver un chemin et à trouver
un chemin notamment assez habilement
avec les organisations syn et puis la
réforme de l’assurance chômage qui est
aussi quand elle était ministre du
Travail cette fois quelque chose
d'extrêmement compliqué il y avait des
annulations contentieuses des reports
etc le covid qui était passé par là et
là là aussi réussi à trouver un chemin
donc il y a 14 textes présentés au vote
solennelle des députés oui ça c'était
globalement pendant la pendant la
première année de de exactement les deux
exemples que je prends sont des exemples
du de la fin du quinquennat précédent du
milieu ou de la fin du quinquennat
précédent mais effectivement ensuite il
y a eu 14 textes alors c'est plutôt
quelque chose d'intéressant par rapport
à la séquence qui va s'ouvrir et qui
débute demain alors je sais pas s'il
faut la dater de demain en termes de
début mais en tout cas avec un une étape
importante demain qui est le fait de
recevoir en bilatéral le détail est
important parce que quand on connaît la
chose sociale on sait toute l'importance
de faire d'organiser des bilatérales au
cours desquels peut vraiment échanger
par rapport à des multilatérales qui
sont beaucoup plus
théâtrales on va dire et ou avec un jeu
de rôle ou chacun
et où on a une forme de nivellement de
ce qui a dit par rapport au fait que
tout le monde est autour de la table
limite le risque par nos interrompre que
tout le monde claque la porte et qui la
table vous avez quelques minutes ou
heures quoi à partir de demain il y a
une série de bilatérales et donc cette
série bilatérale ça peut être quelque
chose d'intéressant pour lancer
désormais un processus où tout le monde
tout le monde gouvernement ça paraît
évident mais partenaires sociaux aussi
où tout le monde a intérêt à retrouver
le chemin de la construction de quelque
chose alors quoi on va le voir mais en
tout cas de la construction de quelque
chose on y reviendra cette ce qui va
s'ouvrir là à partir de demain fin
d'après-midi mais je voudrais quand même
vous entendre sur le 49-3 si vous êtes
là c'est aussi pour nous éclairer
là-dessus et d'abord réécouter là aussi
un extrait marquant de cette première
année d'Élisabeth borneau au pouvoir on
est au soir du second tour des élections
législatives évidemment le camp
présidentiel a perdu sa majorité absolue
en écoute ce soir la situation est
inédite
jamais l'Assemblée nationale n'a connu
une telle configuration sous la
Cinquième République
cette situation constitue un risque pour
notre pays au vu des défis que nous
avons à affronter est-ce que vous
imaginiez à ce moment-là un qu'elle
ferait aussi souvent recours Isabelle
Borno 49-3 je crois qu'elle est deuxième
dans le classement des premiers
ministres dans l'histoire de la 5ème
république juste après Michel Rocca et
puis deux qu'elle réussirait quand même
à faire passer autant de textes dans ce
contexte alors à la première question
oui le 49-3 est quand même conçu
initialement pour ces cas-là de majorité
relative alors on parle souvent de 88
mais il faut pas oublier non plus qu'en
58 lorsque le président de Gaulle est
élu la majorité serrée alors à ce point
on ne l'avait quand même jamais vécu
mais c'est vrai que je pense que c'est
un outil de sortie de crise évidemment
qu'il faut relégitimer et garder
d'ailleurs dans notre arsenal à mon sens
sur la deuxième question réussir à faire
adopter à ton autant de textes j'ai un
peu le sentiment qu'il y a deux points
qui se dégagent de cette utilisation un
petit peu de la majorité relative par
Elisabeth borne d'abord c'est une
première invisibilisation
constitutionnelle c'est à dire qu'au
fond notamment dans les journaux
étrangers pendant très longtemps on a
cru que le 49-3 était une arme du
président de la République parce que
tout le monde a donné la responsabilité
de l'usage du 49-3 a Emmanuel Macron
alors il faut vraiment pas oublier que
c'est sa propre responsabilité
personnelle c'est une décision primo
ministérielle sans aucun contrôle et
autre point c'est les échecs de ces
feuilles de route quand même parce que
il faut pas oublier que c'est la
première et la seule de nos premières
ministres qui a été attiré c'est-à-dire
qu'elle était première ministre attitrée
à l'écologie et à la planification je ne
sais quelle qualificatif c'était la
première fois qu'on avait un Premier
ministre qui avait ce nouveau champ de
compétences on a vraiment rien vu
d'incarner à ce niveau là et encore une
fois sur la réforme des retraites sont
sa mission et elle l'a accepté était
justement celle de d'élargir sa majorité
et c'est vrai que on dit il y a autant
de questions étaient adaptées mais je
crois que sur la question de
l'élargissement des majorités là où
Michel Rocard avait une majorité
relative aussi il a bien mieux jouer
finalement le jeu alternatif un peu à
droite un peu au centre un peu très à
gauche qu'elle n'a pour le moment pas
réussi à mener et c'est vrai que la
mission suicide qui lui reste justement
jusqu'au mois de juillet c'est d'élargir
encore cette majorité à l'assurance je
vous en parliez quand elle était
ministre mais quand elle est à Matignon
le texte passe 303 vote pour sur ça
encore complètement appliqué non plus
puisque on le sait il y a la question
sur une majorité sur ce texte là ou sur
les énergies renouvelables avec les
socialistes on a eu des beaux succès
notamment pendant la session
extraordinaire c'est vrai pendant
juillet août en fait on avait on avait
réussi à travailler avec plus de
consensus il faut dire aussi quand même
une chose de cette période législative
c'est que ça n'est pas un échec pour le
gouvernement et pour le Parlement à tous
les niveaux puisqu'on est beaucoup plus
de propositions de loi les niches
parlementaires ont fonctionné et donc au
fond elle a elle a aussi cette lourde
tâche de laisser l'assemblée si
multipartisanes s'exprimer un peu sans
son contrôle donc c'est aussi une une
tâche difficile à trouver en terme
d'équilibre et qu'aucun Premier ministre
de la 5e n'a jamais eu à à régler avant
elle ils allaient dedans qui veut donc
continuer de réformer de creuser son
sillon dans l'opinion on l'a compris
Mathieu c'est pas facile avec l'omnipré
présence médiatique du président Macron
en ce moment on ne se quitte plus pas un
jour ou presque sans que le président ne
nous donne de ses nouvelles se rendent à
notre chevet ou une livre le fond sa
pensée sur le terrain comme dans les
médias Emmanuel Macron s'est lancé dans
une offensive tous azimut avec un
objectif saturé l'espace médiatique pour
ne plus laisser aux oppositions
évidemment le loisir de dire tout le mal
qu'elle pense de cette politique et
tenter du coup de redorer son blason on
verra ça marche dans les sondages mais
ainsi va quand même ce drôle de
président capable d'alterner les rythmes
d'enchaîner les séquences comme on dit
chez les communicants de nous rejouer le
monde du silence pendant trois mois
depuis le début de l'année au moment où
la réforme des retraites était débattues
avant de se multiplier les prises de
parole comme une logorrhée depuis
qu'elle a été adoptée rendez-vous compte
un carrément d'une semaine on a fait les
comptes deux entretiens fleuves dans la
presse écrite challenge et l'opinion une
interview
[Musique]
toutes ces petites phrases qu'on entend
à longueur d'interview du président
Emmanuel Macron qui a reconnu plusieurs
fois que la réforme des retraites il
aurait dû davantage l'expliquer mais là
il aura ce compte là aucun regret
puisque il le fait même si cette
stratégie comporte quand même quelques
limites quelle limite mais d'abord on
vous le disait tout à l'heure son
omniprésence prise d'oxygène le
gouvernement et puis en plus ce
gouvernement qui parfois soumis je le
disais aussi à des injonctions
contradictoires et pas toujours facile à
utiliser en gros à quoi bon donner un
tempo d'enfer ou de chanter très fort si
personne derrière ne parvient à sugg le
rythme moi danser l'autre risque c'est
que cette omniprésence confortera
peut-être ceux qui le soutiennent ou en
tout cas permettra de stabiliser son
socle voir un petit peu de remonter mais
est-ce que ça ne risque pas d'exaspérer
davantage encore j'avoue que je pose la
question ce qui rejettent aussi bien sa
politique que sa personnalité pierre
Adrien Bartoli en tout cas le premier
public auquel il s'adresse c'est
effectivement
c'est eux qu'il faut consolider on
parlait des différentes prises de parole
excusez-moi l'opinion
journal extrêmement à gauche ou
complètement d'extrême droite challenge
le finden sheltime la semaine dernière
enfin on voit bien quand même que le
public auquel il s'adresse pour le
moment c'est déjà le cœur de cible c'est
déjà ses proches qu'il faut consolider
pourquoi est-ce qu'il faut consolider
parce que l'image du président de la
République c'est quand même
un peu écorné par la séquence il y a eu
un moment donné où c'est sympathisant on
n'était pas franchement favorable au
fond de la réforme oui parce que ça on
le sait mais au moment de la Réforme
est-ce que c'était si urgent de ça de
faire la réforme des retraites
maintenant pas tant que ça au final et
puis ils sont posés la question même de
la capacité à réformer du président de
la République or c'est le principal
argument Emmanuel Macron c'est le
président des cris celui qui protège
d'accord et c'est le réformateur
dynamique qui est le seul qui peut
changer les choses en France pour son
électorat évidemment bon bah le
président qui protège très important
mais on se sent moins exposé au covid
sont moins exposés à la menace de de la
Russie donc on va peut-être moins besoin
de ce président qui protège et le
président réformateur s'il est empêché
dès la première réforme structurante et
symbolique que les retraites il y a
commode donc le premier objectif est
l'essentiel pour le président de la
République c'était déjà de rassurer ces
électeurs et il a plutôt réussi à le
faire en fin de séquence des retraites
ou ces électeurs c'est Macron très large
se sont dit malgré tout et puis par
manque d'alternative encore une fois ça
reste président qu'on a élu on continue
à le soutenir et on reste dans le dans
le sillon alors on va regarder ensemble
d'autres qualificatifs on a vu tout à
l'heure les qualificatifs plutôt
positifs à propos d'Elizabeth borne je
reviens à Elisabeth borne mais vous
allez voir ça va ça concerne pardon son
duo avec le prénom de la République
est-ce qu'elle est capable de tenir tête
à Emmanuel Macron là on a seulement 32%
de oui ensuite sur le côté sympathique
de la première ministre 27 % de 8 73% de
noms alors ça c'est très intéressant on
y revient aussi est-ce que les
[Musique]
aux réforme qui allaient être menées et
en particulier à la réforme des
retraites et puis un peu au contexte de
majorité relative et puis il y a eu
l'épisode Catherine Vautrin que tout le
monde connaît voilà donc c'était un
petit peu en tout cas peut-être le
premier jour en tout cas pressenti avant
Elisabeth voilà avant effectivement de
ne pas être nommé parce que un certain
nombre de positions qu'elle avait pu
prendre dans le passé déplaisait à une
partie de certains ténors de la majorité
non après sur la question de l'équilibre
du duo vous avez deux types de duos sous
la Cinquième République vous avez les
duos qui sont des duos complémentaires
ou le Premier ministre qui est nommé et
un complément du président politiquement
c'était le cas d'Édouard Philippe et
d'Emmanuel Macron c'était le cas si je
remonte un peu plus loin de Michel
Rocard par rapport à François Mitterrand
par exemple et puis vous avez les
premiers ministres qui sont à l'inverse
des premiers ministres plutôt pas clones
mais en tout cas qui se situe plutôt
dans les dans les pas du président ce
qui est assez typique dans le cas
d'Elizabeth borne c'est qu'on pourrait
dire de ce point de vue là qu'elle a
plutôt un profil de deuxième Premier
ministre du mandat ce type de profil
Laurent Fabius avec François Mitterrand
par exemple
c'est plutôt un premier ministre qu'on
rencontre généralement en deuxième
partie de mandat c'est-à-dire un homme
ou une femme du président qui suit
quelqu'un qui avait été nommé pour des
raisons d'équilibre politique voilà
l'avenir dira effectivement ce qu'il en
est par la suite et alors Pierre-Adrien
Bartoli les Français voient pas en
Élisabeth borde une femme de gauche
c'est c'est clair 25% de oui seulement
non parce qu'encore une fois aujourd'hui
l'espace politique est structuré
autrement d'ailleurs ce qui est quand
même particulièrement intéressant c'est
qu'aujourd'hui elle là sa confiance et
elle tire sa confiance davantage des
sympathisants des républicains que des
sympathisants de centre gauche parce que
quelque part elle a pivoté un elle vient
de cet espace macroniste central que les
gens qui aujourd'hui se considèrent
comme étant à gauche auquel ces gens-là
n'adhèrent pas et 2 elle porte une
réforme quand même elle essaie de
changer un petit peu la forme et la
manière de présenter les choses qu'il
rejette nettement donc elle peut pas à
leurs yeux être de gauche NV plus et
d'ailleurs elle n'a même plus l'heure
confiance alors qu'elle l'avait au début
du deuxième quinquennat puis elle était
mature relativement peu identifié comme
une femme de gauche parce que voilà elle
avait pas elle avait pas fait bourse
auprès de Lionel Jospin auprès de enfin
ça c'était pendant que j'ose pas été à
l'éducation nationale et puis ensuite
auprès de Ségolène Royal quand plus tard
mais elle était dans l'ombre mais elle
avait un profil techno qui était pas du
tout étiqueté après la comparaison avec
Édouard Philippe elle est intéressante
parce que d'une certaine façon ils sont
tous les deux arrivés relativement
vierges dans l'opinion quand ils étaient
à Matignon avec une sensibilité
politique mal connue Édouard philippe
était pas très connu comme un homme de
droite les gens qui suivent la politique
le connaissaient très bien mais pour
l'ensemble des Français étaient très peu
connu et ils avaient besoin de pareil
mais Édouard Philippe a su se constituer
un poids politique qu'il n'avait pas en
arrivant en Matignon c'était vraiment il
y avait peu de relais peu de troupes peu
de petits dés identifiés là Elisabeth
borne il reste encore un point
d'interrogation sur ce poids politique
elle est plus proche d'une certaine
façon
d'un Jean Castex qui était un exécutant
loyal au président avec pas un cheveu
qui dépasse si j'ose dire et en tout cas
qui qui appliquait qu'il y avait une
relation de confiance avec le président
elle est plus proche de ça mais sans la
ralentir la relation de confiance avec
Emmanuel Macron donc c'est très curieux
quand vous avez ni vraiment la confiance
du président ni vraiment des troupes
pour vous soutenir mais vous êtes bien
bien isolé et votre avenir est bien
incertain il nous reste quelques minutes
on va se projeter un peu dans dans
l'avenir d'Elisabeth bandes d'abord à
Matignon busina est-ce que un déjà un
premier à remaniement avec Isabelle qui
reste en place
le jeu de la chaise musicale c'est
toujours un petit peu dangereux ça donne
l'impression qu'on remet un petit peu du
neuf avec de l'ancien et c'est pas les
remaniements les plus marquants sous la
Cinquième République le sens politique
du remaniement c'est généralement de
donner un message à une séquence et donc
de presque changer de braquer ou en tout
cas au moins annoncer un nouveau
dialogue ou peut-être une nouvelle
tendance et j'avoue que avec Elisabeth
borne à Matignon alors encore une fois
on l'a dit on n'a pas encore
complètement son identité politique et
je crois que c'est vraiment ça qui est
marquant par rapport à tous les
présidents de la 5 pour tous les
premiers ministres de la 5e République
c'est que on ne perçoit pas vraiment où
est ce sont des accords où est son
accord pour le coup je crois qu'elle a
quand même été choisie sur la fibre
sociale parce que quand on s'amusait à
cocher des cases au départ en se disant
tiens ce sera a priori une femme plutôt
issue des rangs de la gauche on voyait
bien ça faisait partie de son choix elle
a elle a perdu cela pour une ligne plus
libérale que finalement elle essaye de
tempérer donc il y a toute une question
autour de son identité est-ce qu'elle
pourrait porter un remaniement moi j'ai
tendance à penser que ça ne suffira pas
peut-être à clore cette séquence est-ce
qu'il y a une est-ce que c'est une
attente des Françaises
pas particulièrement c'est à dire que
les gens qui sont opposés au
gouvernement vont évidemment vouloir
quelles démissionnent et qu'on change de
Premier ministre et puis les soutiens
sont toujours présents c'est ce qu'on a
dit elle a pas perdu leur confiance non
puis la question du remaniement pourquoi
au final le problème fondamental c'est
que la méthode borne n'a pas fonctionné
on n'est pas une démocratie de compromis
de consensus on le savait on la vérifier
ça marche pas bon une fois qu'on a dit
ça même si on change de Premier ministre
l'équilibre à l'Assemblée nationale va
rester le même et donc le problème a
priori va également rester le même alors
ça devient de la symbolique est-ce qu'on
a besoin de changer de Premier ministre
pour que symboliquement les choses
évoluent peut-être mais très très vite
les institutions vont rattraper la
symbolique et on se retrouvera dans une
situation assez proche Franck Morel le
bal des successeurs est à la fois
amusant à observer pour pour nous et
certainement cruel de l'intérieur
on lit chaque petite phrase de tel ou
tel ministre
voilà d'une ambition de Premier ministre
comment vous l'analysez un grand
classique le bal des successeurs ce qui
ce qui est notable quand même dans la
période actuelle c'est que contrairement
à ce qu'on a pu vivre à d'autres
périodes personne aujourd'hui ne se
hasarde à dire que il existe une
possibilité que la première ministre
reste durant tout le quinquennat oui on
entendait c'était vraiment une hypothèse
pour les prédécesseurs c'est quelque
chose qui s'est produit avec François
Fillon mais c'est quelque chose qu'on
entend quasiment pas qu'on entend
c'était pas gagné pour Fillon
effectivement il y avait eu l'épisode
Borlo vous avez raison de le rappeler
mais en tout cas ça s'est produit et
puis c'est quelque chose qu'on entendait
régulièrement pour Édouard Philippe
c'est quelque chose qu'on entend pas du
tout aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire que on a
tous quasiment acté le fait qu'il y aura
au moins deux premiers ministres durant
ce quinquennat alors après vous avez
raison changer de Premier ministre c'est
un fusil à un coût entre guillemets et
il faut pas se louper parce que le nom
du locataire de Matignon est signifiant
politiquement et dans le contexte actuel
on voit bien que là où la personne sera
attendue c'est sur sa capacité à mettre
en musique ce qu'on pourrait appeler une
forme de cohabilitation
contraction cohabitation coalition
c'est-à-dire de capacité à construire
quelque chose en réalité avec le groupe
charnière que sont les républicains et
ça c'est loin d'être gagné pour
l'instant merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce premier débat à
bientôt sur cette chaîne à bientôt sur
public